bueno
esta situación era posible esperar
puesto que para Rusia
las dos demandas principales para evitar
la guerra pasaban en primer lugar por
una garantía de la otan de No ampliarse
al este y la otra era que se
restituyeran las potestades que tenían
las poblaciones filosas del este de
Ucrania ninguna de las dos demandas
estuvo nunca sobre la mesa tampoco lo
están hoy no está la garantía de no
ampliación más al este de la otan por lo
tanto esto explica por qué Rusia movió
su músculo militar sobre Ucrania de
manera que al llegar a un punto al que
ha llegado la situación de guerra Hoy
era esperable que se repita aquí el
modelo crimea es decir pasaran a ser
parte de la federación rusa por lo menos
se firmó la adhesión de incorporación de
las dos repúblicas y las dos regiones de
porque esta es una jugada que diría
lleva la guerra una situación muy pero
muy peligrosa tal vez la situación más
peligrosa desde que comenzó la guerra el
24 de febrero de este año Alberto pero
la legalidad del kremlin y la legalidad
de el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin de
hacer estos referendos en un territorio
que no es de él en un territorio
ucraniano No porque se da este paso y
cómo podría responder la comunidad
internacional hablamos principalmente de
Estados Unidos desde la Unión Europea y
del otan
bueno Por supuesto que es ilegal lo que
ha pasado en lo referendo solamente son
reconocidos por Rusia no sé si bien los
Rusia me llegó a reconocer el principal
socio en este tema de Rusia pero Rusia
ha hablado por ejemplo del derecho de
autor de autodeterminación pero sobre
todo se ha referido a los derechos
inculcados hace en 2014 antes de 2014 de
2014 incluso por parte de quiebre de
estas poblaciones Por ejemplo
cerrando la posibilidad que tienen estas
poblaciones de emplear el propio idioma
ruso de manera que
Rusia al no al considerar que sobre
estas cuestiones kiev y occidente pero
por fundamentalmente kiev no han hecho
ningún avance
estableció la la la la acción o invasión
militar no de manera que por supuesto
que es un hecho ilegal y reconocible
pero en Rusia por ejemplo dicen que esto
es un poco pasó con kosovo en la década
del 90 No es cierto tampoco fue legal
pero allí hubo una una independencia de
manera que para Rusia al no resolverse
la cuestión principal pasa a
reincorporarla por la fuerza es una
política de fuerza prácticamente porque
este es un tema básicamente geopolítico
Alberto no quiero no quiero despedirlo
sin preguntarle por un Aliado clave de
Rusia hablamos de China digamos el
gobierno de
pudiera hacer algo para Pues de tratar
de no escalar este conflicto bélico
recordemos que tampoco a China le
conviene que esta guerra se sigue
expandiendo toma otro nivel
es una buena acotación la suya porque a
China no le interesa realmente que el
escenario internacional regional se
degrade es decir vaya una situación
donde la confrontación militar asuma a
otra escala puesto que china está
fundamentalmente interesada en la
economía del mundo puesto que allí está
su salida las posibilidades de seguir
creciendo y convertirse en una potencia
más cabal de manera que esto explica
porque china ha tenido hasta hoy un
apoyo moderado a Rusia la ha apoyado en
el Consejo de Seguridad pero no ha ido
mucho más allá pero claro es el
principal cliente comercial para Rusia y
allí puede estar su reemplazo junto con
otros países como India de todo el
material exportable energético que ya no
va a Europa